hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game that you just finished
from the video World Cup 2023
Petersville vs Jordan van Forrest the
beautiful beautiful uh a miniature you
guys will really enjoy this one uh ended
abruptly uh not a lot of time spent on
the clock well one of the players did
but the The Winning Side obviously
didn't and before we check out the game
I would just like to quickly remind
everyone that today we will have a live
stream we will have a tournament on
leeches it is a fundraising event and
another fun a Fund Raising event uh
where we will be raising funds for the
distribution of chess sets across Africa
across African countries and they are
doing incredibly well it is the gift of
Chess Foundation we've had a live stream
with them a couple of months ago if you
guys remember uh they already have some
nine countries I believe covered and
they already have 50 000 chess sets
ready to be deployed their stationed in
warehouses in Kenya and Ghana but it
does it costs around five thousand
dollars to get 1 000 chess sets to uh to
a certain African country and that
includes shipping that includes pretty
much everything so it's five thousand
dollars for that one thousand chess sets
to be distributed to one country in
Africa and uh with this stream we are
hoping to raise ten thousand dollars and
this would cover two countries so uh if
you guys can join the stream uh join the
tournament on leeches and by all means
if you are able to join this goal also
do help out
um it's uh it's definitely for a great
cause I will put a link to the leeches
term in the description below and also
below that I will put a link to this
fundraiser where you can read a lot more
if you are interested on the topic uh
but yeah I mean so far the some of the
countries that they have already reached
with those 1000 uh chess sets are Ghana
Nigeria Kenya Uganda seychos Somalia
malavi Zambia Zimbabwe South Sudan and
Tanzania and of course with your help
they are trying to reach the entire
Africa uh we're gonna have a lot of
guests uh are going to have a lot of fun
you guys will hear about what they've
been doing since the last time they were
on the stream so it's going to be it's
going to be great to join us if you can
it will start 7 PM Central European Time
last for about two hours the leeches
tournament will be an hour and a half
and then maybe the entire thing two
hours so hope you guys can make it that
being said let's check out this
brilliancy as uh it's so short I I fear
uh my intro will be longer than the
actual game but let's check it out as
Fiddler has the white pieces and he
opens with E4 we have font to C5 by
Jordan Knight to F3 we have D6 and now
Pawn to D4 so a standard Sicilian
Defense we have captors captures Knight
to F6 we have Knight to C3 and pawn to
A6 now the neither is on the board
Bishop to G5 and now Pawn to E6 and here
there are many possible continuations F4
being the most popular one you have
Queen T2 you have Queen to F3 you have
Queen to D3 you have Bishop to eat you
have Bishop to C4 so any move is a move
in this position and Thriller plays
an extremely rare one but a fairly rare
one it's it's interesting that this is
move seven and Sevilla replaced the
seventh most popular uh choice in this
position uh but Okay it definitely has
been played before with bishop t7 and
now Pawn to H4 so Queen to E2 combined
with Pawn to H4 if you guys face the
Sicilian a lot you should definitely try
this Pawn to H6 Bishop goes back to D2
uh and queen to B6 now putting pressure
on the B2 Pawn also the Knight on D4 is
hanging with Knight to B3 and now there
are some games where Queen back to C7
were played Knight B the D7 is a normal
but here we have Pawn to H5 by Jordan
and it is now as of move 10 that we have
a completely new game so okay Spiller
castles we have castles and now Queen to
C7 you have to play this move even
though it does seem like loss of a Tempo
uh but you have to play B5 you have to
move the Knight you have to move the
bush we have to put the rook and C8 you
have to play a B5 B4 so the queen
definitely has to move uh we have Rook
to H3 now uh Peter wants to put the Rook
on G3 to put pressure on the G7 Pawn we
have Knight beat the D7 Rook to G3 and
just Pawn to G6 uh Jordan happy with his
King in the center of the board we have
Bishop to G5 and now Pawn to B5 now of
course Jordan will start his attack on
the queen side we have A3 and now Bishop
to B7 now putting some pressure on the E
for pawn queen back the E1 freeing up
the light Square Bishop we have rooked
the C8 now putting pressure on that C2
point you have to be careful if the
Knight moves you're gonna get checkmated
and the bishop to D3
since the queen made room for the bishop
with Knight the C5 and now just King the
B1 and we will pretty much always see
when
um a White Castle's Queen side against
the Sicilian Defense we have castles uh
and now Knight captures on C5 and this
is where the fun starts uh the safest
move here is Queen captures on C5 but uh
Jordan is not going for safety he's
going for an attack he plays D captures
on C5 now he also has B4 coming but the
problem is Peter moves first he plays
Pawn to E5 and now again Knight the G
for is what you should play Knight G4
then let's take captures captures and
then you go F3 you kick away the Knight
Knight comes to H6 it's a bit of a weird
square but then maybe you can go to F5
later on and you're gonna have a uh a
defendable position but here Knight the
D5 was played and now look at what Peter
plays Knight captures on D5 Bishop
characters on D5 and believe it or not
black is already lost here it's very
hard to actually make a pause the video
moment in this game because so many
moves are important but Peter's next
move is what is crucial about his attack
and if you guys can spot it this one
you're not just an excellent attacker
you are also a complete chess player so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the absolute best move for white
while I give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
Unstoppable move and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
Queen to E3 this is the move and now
black is without any moves to give you
uh to give an example what can black
play Let's Play Bishop captures on G5
okay Queen captures and how are you
stopping this bishop captures and G6 is
the next Queen captors and H5 is next
there's really no move you can make uh
to stop this from happening so okay
we're gonna avoid that let's try
something else let's play King stage
seven let's add another Defender to the
G6 Pawn not a problem Bishop captures
Queen characters and now Roo G5
threatening Rook captures on H5 as the G
Pawn is pinned and I've Keen to G7 now
you'll play G4 and if H characters now
you play H5 and again you are breaking
through on that G6 Pawn so uh uh Jordan
tries something else he plays Pawn to C4
but now as Fiddler starts not by playing
Bishop captures on E7 and now he starts
with Bishop captures and G6 and it's
pretty much the same idea there's just
no way out of this F capture Sun G6
other moves don't really help Bishop
captures an E7 Queen captures and Rook
captures on G6 with check and now what
do you do uh there are a couple moves
you could play let's say you play King
to F7 this runs into Queen H6 now
threatening Rook G7 check to pick up the
the black queen and if you move the king
it doesn't really help now you just play
Rook characters on D5 remove the
defender of the E6 spawn and after Pawn
characters Rook to E6 again wins the
queen yes you do have two Rooks but
white is much much better the past E
Pawn is already far too strong for
example D4 you can just trade captures
captures and not trade capture the queen
and after the king moves you will pick
up the D4 Pawn so there's no counter
play here for black so instead of King
the h8 was played but now Peter just
plays uh Rook to H6 with check there was
another way to go about this you could
also play root captures on D5 but it's
it's just incredible how many moves are
winning here for for upon captures now
Queen to H6 with the check Queen to H7
and now look at this queen to G5
threatening Rook to H6 to win the black
queen and if Rook to G8 then you have
Queen to F6 check Rogue blocks and now
Rook to H6 again winning the black queen
so I obviously that did not happen Rook
the H6 was played like I mentioned with
King to G7 and here uh you could again
uh try some some other moves but Rook
captures an H5 was played uh and he was
in this position and move 27 that Jordan
van Forest resigned the game as there is
really nothing more to be done here to
give an example let's say you try
running away with a king king to F7 Rook
H7 check picks up the queen okay we can
play that can we play King to G8 does
this help us at all Rook captures on D5
it seems like okay maybe you don't even
have to play this but the bishop here is
so strong and you know it definitely is
harder for white to play than when you
play Rook captures on D5 so after he
captures the queen to G3 with check King
to F7 and again Rook to H7 check will
pick up black queen and again you have
all the all the same tricks and of
course one move that we still haven't
tried is a rook the h8 how about you
stop Rook to H7 or any such ideas
altogether uh not gonna work Queen to G3
checking F7 and now Queen to F4 with
check King to G7 now you play Rook to G5
with check King to H7 and now finally
Rook captures on D5 and that's it pawn
captures now Queen to F5 with check King
to H6 and of course Queen to G6 will be
Checkmate so really uh just a very very
hard to figure out what went wrong but I
think that people will start playing
this a lot more and by this I mean this
line with Queen to E2 followed by Pawn
to H4 because if you play against the
neither of chances are you uh get this
position a lot and this bishop G5 Queen
to E2 H4 uh just seems like
uh well it just seems very fresh or
we've seen a lot of attempts uh going at
the neither but this one uh we have not
seen at least on this channel I believe
we haven't and uh where did Jordan go go
wrong again very very hard to say
probably it all started here after he
played Knights of the C5 now just uh he
wanted to go aggressive with the
characters and see if I probably Queen
captures was safer uh and then again
that Knight to G4 so those were the two
moves where he could have played a
little bit better but he didn't and
Peter just took advantage of that so
there we have it once again uh you see
just how strong Peter swiller is he's uh
you know still defending the honor of
the Old Guard where you know the players
learn to play without use of engines and
you make one one positional mistake and
he will absolutely destroy you uh so
yeah that's uh the game hope you guys
enjoyed a big congratulations to Peter
on such a such a Brilliance against the
Knight of like I said I'm pretty sure
Queenie too uh uh H4 line will will
become uh very popular online I would
like to thank sure Paul Harris Samuel
Kane Aaron is the best wife and no Laura
is the best wife for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day do join us later on the leeches
event um and also to try to support the
give to chess Foundation if you can
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day